well tonight in Eyewitness News
exclusive thriving video showing a woman
being pushed into the side of a subway
train we told you about the attack last
night now eyewitness news reporter
Stefan Kim has exclusive details about
it and how the NYPD was able to make an
arrest so quickly it is a terrifying
subway shove during last night's evening
commute in this Eyewitness News
exclusive you can see the suspect
approach her victim from the right of
your screen and then violently push the
woman wearing a red hat right into an
oncoming Train The unprovoked Assault
captured by police body worn cameras two
officers standing on the platform where
it happened just after 5 30 last night
that's stupid you did that [__] in front
of the cops bro
and their body cam was working God damn
arrested the suspect right away you can
hear the horrified victim pleading for
help
it happened at the Lexington Avenue 59th
Street Station the 31 year old victim
bounced off the first car of a
southbound 6 train as it barreled into
the station and landed back on the
platform I'ma say this this is me
partially taking the subway in the Metro
all the time I am always nervous about
having people behind me before
up so you best believe I keep my
distance away from the thing until it's
past me because I've always been afraid
of that very scenario look I'm not
saying This Woman's to blame for this
obviously not she's just standing there
some random person pushed her that's
[__]
slow her for attempted murder okay
because that's a terrifying way to die
one and two oftentimes people who fall
in front of trains don't die they get
dragged and mangled right they get like
severely amputated because of the
injuries of the state of being dragged
by a Subway what a terrible way to get
hurt because because the subway is not
going to stop right there and then no
it's going right for some time
oh man well just the thought of that
[__] freaks me out man oh man I've
looked at Subway like like subway tracks
when they're empty so many times and
aside from seeing like rats run through
I just keep thinking like what if I fell
so I'd be standing far back I don't know
if you guys get the same fear I don't
know if y'all like me but I always think
like what if somebody pushes me or what
if I trip and fall so let me just wait
let me just wait and you wanna know
what's crazy about this
they don't even know each other this was
random random I'm provoked random and we
don't know why she did it was she
mentally ill was she
what a crazy thing that's crazy for
someone you don't even know it was
harrowing his jarring for all New
Yorkers to see NYPD Transit Chief
Kathleen O'Reilly says just seconds made
a difference between life and death had
she hit the front of that train the
outcome would have been much different
with the split second that young lady
could have lost her life but for the
grace of God that did not happen luckily
for us our offices where they're
supposed to be on the platforms They
Ride the trains they're in the in the
stations they immediately took action 33
year old Linda Chavez of Queens was
taken into custody and charged with
attempted murder and assault if those
cops weren't here to immediately arrest
that suspect one has to wonder would she
have ever been arrested or could she
have pushed someone else before they
eventually caught her that's real stuff
and this has actually been happening
pretty often in New York uh and in the
subway itself apparently it's a very
common occurrence oh very common that's
a bit stretch but I meant that it
happens enough times well there's a lot
of people so the it's possible that it
happens more often yeah you know about
people who jump in front and obviously
there's people who try to take their own
lives but some people get pushed on but
we want to begin with that disturbing
video from Union Square a man runs
towards a woman on the platform and
shoves her onto the tracks right in
front of an oncoming train somehow she's
okay lucky to be alive the suspect now
under arrest eyewitness news reporter
Diana Rocco with the story she's live at
that subway station Diana if you've ever
been to New York and see the platforms
the way they work it's like the tracks
are in the middle but there's a little
bit like of a rise on the sides of each
side the way she felt she could easily
cracked her head and broken her skull
right there you you get what I'm saying
like absolutely that's super dangerous
to even push someone without the train
right because also there's electric
current that's passing through so if you
touch those you fry that's happening
when you fry you don't necessarily die
no so you are in excruciating pain pain
and there's just people can smell skin
melting yeah yeah it's very very
gruesome smells like pork by the way for
those who you want to know
uh-huh probably an anxiety just thinking
about it it's a it's a real it's a real
thing and Bill as you just saw there
this video is so hard to watch this
video is so hard to watch let's show it
to you in slow motion by all accounts
tonight it really is a miracle that this
woman survived all of this meanwhile
after a number of incidents just like
this on subway platforms recently the
interim Transit Authority president had
some very harsh words for the mayor
demanding he take action immediately
saying Riders have a right to feel safe
this 24 year old homeless man is now in
the custody of police charged with
attempted murder police say this is the
suspect caught on this disturbing
surveillance video posted to Twitter
pushing a 40 year old woman in front of
a moving five train during this
morning's commute it happened in front
of other Riders I want you guys to pay
attention to everyone else who's just
watching one man thinks he just
witnessed a murder
right another person is reacting trying
to stop the person and other people
literally just started running for help
the unintended consequences things like
these and just seeing that we like that
[__] up everyone else as well and it
doesn't matter if the lady survive no
that person saw that yeah scarred for
life scarred for life it's over so yeah
so the book of this man and make sure
you don't come out because at the end of
the day when you psychologically damage
somebody like that with something so
heinous
I'm not with that other writers on the
platform and a Transit worker who keeps
the suspect on the platform until police
arrive
well yeah that guy is traumatized that
guy is traumatized he lived thankfully
but that'll make him no no no yeah no no
it's over yeah you saw that it's very
disturbing we've seen him waiting
calculating for the the train to
approach the station and at the
opportune moment he pushed the uh the
victim to uh to the to the to the
platform to the tracks the two never
exchanged words you see the suspect
waiting on the Northbound 5-train
platform in Union Square around 8 30
this morning for the right time police
say when the train pulled in he shoved
the unsuspecting woman in its path the
victim fell underneath the tracks but by
all accounts is lucky to be alive she
failed fortunately for her between the
roll bed and the rails this is the
second incident in two days on subway
platforms yesterday police arrested
23-year-old Justin Pina for punching a
man in his 60s on the F train both
suspects wearing similar red athletic
pants and both now in custody
is in the city and it absolutely has to
be addressed it can't just land in the
transit system because we're underground
the transit authorities interim
president had some harsh words for the
mayor saying this is a small part of a
much bigger problem and riders need to
feel safe pandemic or not have you ever
been in New York
that public transit system is crazy
the people that get on there [__]
Wild
wild I've been to a lot of transit
systems and the only one worse than that
one that I've ever experienced is the
one Los Angeles which is just degeneracy
completely but the one in New York is
I mean you go see some things I'm gonna
just tell you that now people say you
need to make these things safer you know
what I did see once when I was in Brazil
in Sao Paulo they have parakeets they're
like barricades they're basically like
uh glass seals that cover everything
except for the uh um door entrance right
and so basically people can't just jump
on and then obviously it opens when when
the thing get there so I think
that while expensive is to me the only
solution that you have to this kind of
stuff
um what do you think yeah I think that
should be implemented yeah definitely
like just whenever you go every
underground system of of
airports that I've been in
they have those things yes you can't go
in because they don't have time airports
don't have time they can't afford you
can't afford to miss your flight to me
to every to miss everybody's life
because someone jump in they cannot so
they block off the whole thing and when
they open you can't even no no no no no
it's locked it's locked stop we ain't
got time for this it's really that yes
it's all blocked off and that would be a
good thing yeah I would definitely be a
good thing you know what's terrifying
about the second video is that that's a
middle platform meaning there's two
trains passing on each side so that
means there's no place to put your back
against especially during rush hour like
you don't have an option no right you
can put your head against maybe the one
of the beams but that's not really a
thing so you're at the mercy of some
[__] lunatic if he wants to do
something yeah right and that's never a
good place to be so uh I think there's
no easy solution to this and again both
times they didn't even know the person
they just did it you don't have to be
looking for it sometimes the problems
just find you and so you know I hope the
people who were hurt you get a speedy
recovery but but yeah that's [__] up
man that's [__] up that's great let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below how do you you guys make these
kinds of things safer what do you think
is a solution to this and and yeah is
this something that you guys are afraid
of we want to hear from you